BARRELS A DAY WITHIN ONE OR
TWO MONTHS.
WE ARE LEARNING NEW DETAILS
TONIGHT ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED
TO TRIGGER AIR RAID SIRENS
THURSDAY IN TEL AVIV AND
THEN THE RESPONSE TO IT.
CORRESPONDENT TREY YINGST
FILLS US IN FROM OUR MIDDLE
EAST NEWSROOM.
>> TWO ROCKS FIRED FROM THE
HAMAS GAZA STRIP TOWARDS TEL
AVIV WERE LIKELY LAUNCHED BY
MISTAKE.
DESPITE THAT ASSESSMENT BY
THE IDF, ISRAEL STRUCK 100
DIFFERENT TARGETS IN GAZA.
AS ISRAELI AIRSTRIKES
POUNDED HAMAS POSITIONS,
MILITANTS BEGAN FIRING MORE
ROCKETS TOWARDS SOUTHERN
ISRAEL.
ISRAEL'S MISSILE DEFENSE
SYSTEM THE IRON DOME
INTERCEPTED MOST OF THE
LAUNCHES.
AND BY THE TIME THE SUN ROSE
IN THE MIDDLE EAST THIS
ROUND OF VIOLENCE APPEARED
TO HAVE FINISHED.
PALESTINIANS HAVE RALLIED ON
THE BORDER BETWEEN ISRAEL
AND GAZA FOR NEARLY A YEAR
DEMANDING ACCESS TO FUEL,
ELECTRICITY, AND CLEAN
WATER.
AS PART OF CURRENT
CEASE-FIRE UNDERSTANDINGS,
TODAY WAS THE FIRST FRIDAY
IN 51 WEEKS THAT NO
DEMONSTRATIONS TOOK PLACE
ALONG THE BORDER HAMAS SAYS
IT IS PREPARED TO FIGHT
AFTER THIS ROUND OF VIOLENCE
IF CONFLICT BREAKS OUT
AGAIN.
>> OUR PEOPLE WILL CONTINUE
THEIR STRUGGLE DESPITE THIS
AGGRESSION TO BREAK THE
[INAUDIBLE]
>> ON THE ISRAELI SIDE, THE
PAST 24 HOURS OF ESCALATION
TURNED INTO A POLITICAL
DEBATE ON HOW TO DEAL WITH
THE VIOLENCE FROM GAZA
BENJAMIN NETANYAHU HAS BEEN
CRITICIZED BY MEMBERS OF HIS
OWN CABINET WHO CALLED HIS
RESPONSE OVERNIGHT QUOTE
PATHETIC.
HIS OPPONENT IN THE UPCOMING
ISRAELI ELECTRICS AND HIS
FORMER CHIEF OF STAFF SHOULD
SHOULD NOT EVER ALLOW
ROCKETS TO BE FROM GAZA.
>> WE CANNOT ACCEPT ANY
VIOLATION IN OUR SECURITY
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER IT'S
IN THE GAZA STRIP.
>> WHOEVER IS ISRAEL'S NEXT
PRIME MINISTER WILL LIKELY
FACE MORE ROCKET FIRE FROM
GAZA.
BUT NOW WITH PALESTINIAN
FACTIONS THERE RECEIVING
MILITARY SUPPORT FROM
COUNTRIES LIKE IRAN, THE